[Music]
all right as mentioned previously the
arizona cardinals with that first
overall pick doing their damnedest to
keep it quiet as to what they plan to do
and for a variety of reasons whether
it's something could happen to kyler
murray between now and next thursday or
maybe they get blown away by an offer to
trade out of that spot or maybe they
just changed their mind or ultimately
they want to keep it all secret to prop
up the ultimate reality show about
nothing that will be on multiple
networks next thursday night steve kahn
the jam of the cardinals said something
yesterday that made me even more
convinced they are trying their damn
just to throw dirt on the tracks that
lead back to
kyler murray he was asked whether it's
unusual for an agent to accompany a
player for a visit because there was a
report from nfl media that eric
burkhardt who represents kyler murray
went with him to the visit to the
cardinals kyme said i've never had one
next question that didn't happen last
week with kyler and kyme said no
the reality is it did now this may be a
matter of technicality that the agent
didn't actually go into the building
when it was time for the visit but he
was in town and obviously when you're in
town for a visit with an overnight stay
you go out to dinner you get together
the agents available to talk to anyone
from the team and i think they are
trying their damnedest to conceal the
idea that the agent was there and i
think it's entirely possible to talk to
the agent about a contract because guys
if i'm gonna draft this guy i want him
to sign right before i pick him a
contract that says no baseball under any
circumstances for the next four years
that way you eliminate the possibility
you pick the guy and he has a change of
heart either now or next year or the
year after and he says see you later
football i'm going back to the oakland
a's so i think there's reason why the
agent was there and i think the fact
that kim is trying to make it sound like
he wasn't is just part of this effort to
keep it all as quiet as possible and
make us all not realize that this all is
going to lead to kylie murray in eight
days yeah well i think the first thing
that like jumps out to me mike i mean
when did this first get reported what
was this a week ago ten days ago how
long ago was this when kyler murray it
was about a week to 10 days ago yeah
right so uh for me the first thing i
want to say is
if that was being reported at the time
and you were really worried about the
way everything looked in public
perception i just feel like the arizona
cardinals or steve kaim would have came
out right then when the report came out
and said no the agent you're wrong he
wasn't in town this is this but he was
but they didn't shout it down then
because he was i know that
that's what i'm just i'm just saying
that that that the optics of what steve
kaim is saying and now saying no he
wasn't here and all that yeah to me i'm
just not buying it just because of that
and yeah you're right it seems like it's
more of a technicality answer he's given
they might have met at chili's down the
street but he wasn't at the facility so
therefore you know we didn't have a
meeting or whatever it may be yeah
chili's is the new golf course that
business gets done that is true the new
yeah there you go a little office
reference right there uh
the cardinals are just trying to keep
this
you know illusion that they would be
willing to trade that the first pick
might be open because what happens if a
team shows up and says hey we will give
you multiple first-round picks both this
year and next year yeah they have to do
it sure so there's
it's smart for them to basically try to
keep pushing this narrative and say kylo
murray is not a sure thing
the technicality i agree is is a little
ridiculous but if you're the cardinals
you do want to keep pushing everyone to
a point where it's like hey this first
pick it can be had it's not a guarantee
we haven't met with the agent in a
formal manner maybe at the chili's but
not at the facility and come get it if
you want it
and it was 21 years ago that the
cardinals moved down from number two to
number three so the chargers could take
ryan leaf and the cardinals got two
first-round picks a second-round pick
and two players just for dropping down
one spot so there's something to be said
for that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports